The time has come to check out the
mobile app for conference central. We pre-built one for
android, and if you have an android device you
can also try it out on that device. Please
see the instructor notes. This app will work
towards a conference central instance hosted by Udacity. But
remember, since you used cloud end points when you
develop Conference Central. You could also make this app
work if you recompile it towards fewer Conference
Central instance. So, here is the Udacity Conference Central
app and when I select it I need to select a user account. So, I select one here.
After that, I immediately get to the main screen,
which displays all the conferences that have been registered.
So here you can see all the conferences created,
in the conference central instance, hosted by Udacity. Should a
user add a conference using the web browser interface,
for example. They would also show up here, since the
Android device, and the web browser. Using the Cloud
Endpoints API to talk to the conference central server. When
I select a conference, for example, the power of chron
jobs, I can also see the details for the conference.
I can also see the max attendees, and that there
are two seats left that are available. If I click
register, I get registered to the conference. And I can
see which conferences I am registered in, by this check
mark on the right. And if I go back to
the conference details, you can now see that the seats available
have been decremented to one. Now, I have
the option to unregister from a conference. And as
you can see, when I do that, this
mark disappears and, again, the available seats are two.
And that's the power of cloud endpoints. When
you create your API in this way you can
access your server application from any device. Let's look
in a little more detail on how it works.